judge jeanine pirro is the host of
course of justice with judge jeanine she
joins us tonight with her reaction to
the trial judge thanks a lot for coming
on what do you make of this
well i think that along with your with
your last guest jd vance what we're
seeing here is the politization of the
criminal justice system this is a case
where clearly self-defense
is is something that will exonerate kyle
rittenhouse and whether this case goes
to the jury or whether the judge
dismisses some of the charges on his own
or whether the judge grants a mistrial
this young man will be uh acquitted and
exonerated what has happened here is
there was a rush to judgment in this
case
this kid who was a you know a fire cadet
a lifeguard and a police explorer he was
a kid who went there to clean graffiti
they have video of it he went there to
help people he was a medic he was cpr
trained and he finds himself in this
situation he's got a gun and in every
circumstance he is and it's corroborated
by what the witnesses say the the
prosecution star witness the one who
isn't dead basically said yes i was
lunging at him and i had a loaded gun
and i was aiming at him i mean they
established the case right there as a
judge i would say hey come up to the
sidebar here what are we doing here guys
but what you had was a rush to judgment
in august of 2020. we are in the
post-george floyd world jacob blake had
just been shot everybody wanted to make
sure that you know that everyone was
prosecuted this kid was prosecuted when
the evidence was clear that he was
defending himself now once the burden of
proof has shifted once he claims
self-defense the prosecution has to
disprove that beyond a reasonable doubt
that's why the prosecution is desperate
right now they're on the ropes the
reason they're on the ropes is they
cannot disprove beyond a reasonable
doubt based on the drone the video the
testimony of the prosecution star
witness and the incredibly focused
testimony of this young man he may only
be 18 but i'll tell you in all the years
i prosecuted myself and tried cases as a
judge this kid in every point never lost
his cool sure he cried he never got
angry he said all i wanted to do was
stop the threat i wasn't interested in
in killing people it was not my intent
he he knew what he was doing he knew how
to handle a gun and the whole course of
the whole force of the justice system
from the president on down to the
mainstream media calling him a vigilante
a white supremacist a militia man i mean
this is what happens in our society when
police are told to stand down when no
one is there to protect businesses
police were nowhere around there this
guy rosenbaum you had his number tucker
he was someone who was looking for
trouble he was they were yelling cranium
him between shoot him in the head they
were chasing him they were trying to
kill him with a skateboard and the the
prosecution's saying oh kill you with a
skateboard that deserves lethal force
sure does when you hold it like a
baseball bat and you hit me in the head
with it i mean come on why this case
went forward why there wasn't a police a
plea bargain of some sort but this will
end up i think in a good thing for uh
kyle rittenhouse i hope so
yeah the convicted child musters out of
the mental hospital that's who they're
defending
great to see you tonight thank you very
much thank you tucker hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else